Google Related is a new tool that makes it easy to discover useful stuff while you browse.
When you visit a website, Related finds useful content relevant to the pager viewing.
A thin bar will appear at the bottom of your browser,...
...suggesting news, images, and much more in real time.
Let's say you're looking at a website about your favorite singer or band.
Google Related will show teasers for on - topic related content.
Hover your mouse over the video section and watch without leaving the page you're on.
Want to find a place where you can grab a bite to eat?
When you visit a local restaurant's website...
...Related can show you maps, reviews and even other nearby restaurants.
All of the links open in new tabs or windows so you don't have to worry about being navigated away from the original page.
Whether you're reading the news, shopping for a new phone...
...checking out a local hot spot or just browsing the web...
Google related can help you discover even more useful and interesting content.
Google Related is free and easy to install in Chrome and Internet Explorer.
Visit google.com/related to start using it today.